Okay, let's go.
- Rock, paper, scissors!
Congratulations! You win, Jabami.
What next?
Let's see.
Shall we go with 50 chips once more?
Are you kidding me?
Didn't you get burned enough?
Interesting.
I like that kind of spirit.
Here we go.
- Rock, paper, scissors!
Great minds do think alike.
Here we go again.
We have a...
- Tie!
Yes! I win yet again!
Thanks for the 500,000.
That's one million yen, total.
All right, next!
Let's keep rolling, shall we?
Is something wrong?
Don't tell me you're getting cold feet.
Well, after losing one million yen,
who can blame you?
No, the showdown
is just about to start.
Please bet two chips this time around.
It's over. 216 chips versus 24 chips.
The gap is way too huge.
Her back's up against the wall.
She'll never pull off an upset
if she's freaked out.
Then let's carry on.
Rock, paper, scissors!
Scissors!
Oh, my, Jabami.
I see you've run out of chips.
- Did she just lose 1.2 million yen?
- That was a huge gamble.
Mary, would you mind playing
just one more game?
Don't do it, Jabami!
At the rate you're going,
you'll be a house pet on your first day.
Of course!
How much do you want to bet?
Idiot. You'll only get yourself mired
with no way out.
Ten million yen in cash.
Why would you walk around
with that amount of cash?
Don't be ridiculous!
Staking ten million yen on a single
casual game of Rock-Paper-Scissors.
You...
You're insane!
Isn't that what makes it fun? Insanity
is the essence of gambling, right?
In a capitalistic society,
money and life are the same.
Trusting your life to fortune,
no one in their right mind would do that.
And yet, people still throng casinos
because people derive pleasure
from the insanity of risking their lives.
In that case, the more insane you are,
the more you enjoy gambling!
Now, then,
let's get our gambling freak on.